hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
it's been a while since the last video
those of you who watch regularly all 12
of you will know I've been moving house
lately and as such I've been very busy
with doing all of the moving house stuff
you know documents and that but I'm now
into the house and it's very nice thank
you nearly finished working on the bio
lab that's my home office slash gym and
you can expect a video on that very
shortly but for now I'm going to make
something a little bit short just to get
back into the swing of things let us get
reacquainted I'm going to count down my
top nootropics
nootropics as most of you will know are
smart drugs supplements and medications
that can make you smarter or in some way
boost cognitive performance in one
aspect or another that we pronounced new
otro pics I believe but I am NOT going
to say that because I've been saying
nootropics for years I read it before I
heard it and most people say nootropics
and frankly neurotropic sounds dumb
so nootropics it is the nootropics i
want to look at today are the favourites
that I use I've made some videos on this
subject before I've talked about
modafinil I've talked about piracetam
I've done a guide to no topics and how
they work in all these videos I've
basically said messing with your
neurotransmitters is a mistake and it
can lead to actually decreased cognitive
performance in some capacities even if
it might lead to some improvements in
other areas it can also cause problems
like tolerance dependence even good old
caffeine can do that leaving you
addicted and that might make you think
oh it doesn't like nootropics I totally
just make videos about more time and I
don't have a problem with nootropics
it's just stimulants and things like
modafinil that I'm not such a big fan of
so I thought I'd talk to you about the
ones I do like and the alternatives you
know what else is out there that can
give you a slight cognitive boost but
before we go into this the caveat I want
to point out is that none of these are
going to be like the limitless pill none
of them are going to turn you into
wherever his name is from limitless or
the other limitless program that's on
these are slight improvements to your
brain's health long-term cognitive
benefits mild subtle you're not going to
suddenly see the world differently in
wider angle view and with higher
definition if you're looking something
like that that's not really a nootropic
it's probably some kind of drug so
instead of trying to feel weird look for
no cherry pick that makes you just feel
like you but on a good day that's when
you know it's working so what products
can do that I'm going to show you my
favorite now so let's start off with one
you know I said that there's no such
thing as a real limitless pill well this
one is literally called limitless brain
so not a big fan of that brand
as I mentioned the previous video
because it's a little bit derivative I
think they may have been inspired by the
same film in TV program the most people
associate with new traffic's and this is
one of those stimulants it's not what I
normally take and it's not what I highly
recommend but it does have its place
when you do need just waking up boosting
I drink loads of caffeine and this is a
well-made one if that's what you're
after I like this one because there's no
proprietary ingredients there's to say
that they list everything on the website
including the quantities of what you're
actually getting their generous portions
and it's a sensible stack that they've
given you here so like I said this is a
stimulant it's got caffeine in it that's
probably what you're going to fill most
so be more awake but you know what
caffeine is has got caffeine in it it's
also got l-theanine in it which is a
naturally-occurring xanthine that's also
found in green tea and it has the
opposite effect in some ways to caffeine
in the ditch a little bit of an Angela
ticket calms it down and it can take the
edge off the caffeine it's one the most
popular stacks and if you look for many
of these branded supplements that are
popping up online often the key two
ingredients are caffeine and Nell
feeling so you're going to get a similar
experience with most of them it's also
got stuff that boosts a sitar choline
it's got but Coppa just generally stuff
that or maybe a little bit more alert
and there's been shown in studies to
have small benefits so it's not gonna
get you sleep wired but it is gonna snap
you up and I actually do feel this on
working but like I say I don't think
that stimulant is the way to go if you
want to just generally improve your
brainpower because if you're stimulated
then it's like you're forcing your brain
into a certain state into a more awake
state and when you do that you prevent
yourself and be able to switch between
an awake state and a calm state calm
States actually when we're most creative
because then the brain has the
opportunity to explore different your
pathways and connect to disparate ideas
I'm a focus we're so focused on what
we're doing we get tunnel vision that we
can't see alternative solutions caffeine
is essentially stress in a cup which is
great when you need to wake up but it's
not great as something to rely on to
give you a complete cognitive boost if
you want something that's a step up from
just plain old caffeine then limitless
brain is one of the
better products that fall into that
category and I basically recommend it
but not for daily use just for when you
want waking up so what do I like to use
on a daily basis what kind of nootropics
do I recommend well
I generally like nutrition so things are
going to make you healthier I like to
look at nootropics just as additions to
the diet things that are hard to get
normally from your food just to make
sure that they're there and that boost
and support non brain function vitamin
and mineral supplements are something
that kind of fallen out of favor I
should be given them an Super Ted shape
by my mom after dinner but as I get
older a lot of people say why get
vitamins and minerals from your
supplements when you could just get them
from your diet and your body would
absorb them better and then be available
in best ratios that's all very good and
well in theory but it is hard to get all
the things you need from your diet and
you know with the best will in the world
we don't always manage it and a lot of
people say that you can't absorb
vitamins and minerals that well from
supplement but I'm not so sure on that
because well for starters when I take
this one which is just one intended to
boost immunity Men's Health lab body
defense I find that it actually does
make me feel more awake more jolly it's
got such a large amount of vitamin C in
it and how much exactly it's got a six
hundred twenty-five percent of your
recommended intake of vitamin C and
vitamin C is a precursor to serotonin a
feel-good hormone I do feel better when
I take it vitamin C is great for
preventing overtraining if you workout
it's great for boosting your immunity to
prevent illness and if you want to know
what's going to really ruin your
productivity and your mental performance
then feeling ill and those
pro-inflammatory cytokines are exactly
what I'm going to do it also contains
vitamin D which may boost your sleep it
boost testosterone most of us they get
enough vitamin D and it contains zinc
which is very good for brain plasticity
so they say so in general it's a great
thing to have and I say I feel the
benefits and also there's a supplement
called Soylent that's available on
Kickstarter now it was funded on
Kickstarter and people now taking it
Soylent is a supplement intended to
replace your entire need to eat
supposed to contain all of the nutrition
that you need just to survive and people
are living on this and they're not dying
so they must be absorbing it I'm not
saying you should take toyline I think
that's a probably a bad idea but the
fact of the matter is that you can
absorb nutrients from supplements and so
I don't know why supplements like
vitamins and minerals have got such a
bad rap when actually they do a lot of
good and they don't do any harm and the
other one I take from Men's Health and
doesn't have immense health I just think
I bind I absorb this one particularly
well and I like what's in it and this
one I was curious
not as impressed but yes this one is
mental focus and it's just a b-complex
supplement and vit b vitamins are very
good for brain as well because b6 is a
precursor to many important
neurotransmitters and b12 helps blood
flow to the brain they all do important
stuff I mean it's not the best
supplement this one
the choice of vitamin b12 for instance
is co cyano cobalamin okay so that which
is which turns to cyanide in the body if
you get too much not as dangerous as it
sounds but there are better sources of
b12 they chose them the cheap one
basically and seeing as men's health I
think like to position their supplements
as a kind of premium brand with a price
to reflect they're a bit disappointed
with their choice there so I'm not
saying get men's health particularly I
do like the body lab defense one but I'm
just saying that getting a vitamin and
mineral supplement is actually really
great for brain I think anyone
interested in nootropics s really where
you should start this isn't really
considered a nootropic by most people
but it certainly has nootropic
properties ZM a hat zinc magnesium and
vitamin b6 so why a is between b6 I
don't know it's probably very good
reason for it but anyways this is just
three simple minerals but it's been
shown in studies to boost your
testosterone if you take it just before
you go to sleep and to enhance the
quality of your sleep and of course
sleep is the best nootropic there is if
you get better quality sleep
then you wake up feeling way better I
tried this once before and I wasn't that
blown away by it
but having moved house I wasn't getting
that much sleep you know adjusting to
the new bed and I found this probably
does actually make some difference
and yeah for now I'm now stick with it
as well as increasing testosterone zinc
and magnesium are also implicated in
brain plasticity that of course is the
ability of our brain to grow and change
shape as we're learning and seeing as
lots of new neural connections are
created as we're sleeping at the very
least using zinc magnesium to boost
sleep should also have a knock-on effect
on on your plasticity and help us to
cement the things we've learned during
the day but I do have a problem with
this because this contains a lot of zinc
and so does the body defense contain a
lot of zinc too much zinc and there are
downsides to zinc overdose so yeah I
shouldn't leave you take them in both at
the same time which is why I don't which
means I have to pick which one I want
and I like for body lab defense a lot
because I can feel the benefit and I
like the Zetas mace so that's annoying
which which one do I use I'm going to
replace this with magnesium 308 which is
a type of magnesium that's supposed to
be very good for brain plasticity which
I haven't tried yet but I'll be talking
about that in future but that's
something that's a tip as well when
you're creating a supplement stack with
it for bodybuilding or whether it's for
nootropics you just you need to make
sure you read all the ingredients find
out what's in it because you might well
be taking the same thing twice and that
can lead to problems you could cause
more damage than good Omega 3 not
exactly new everyone knows what Omega 3
fish oil is but yeah I just highly
recommend taking it the benefits of
omega-3 in the brain or that it improve
cell membrane permeability cell membrane
is obviously the walls around the cell
and they need to communicate with the
other cells the other neurons in the
brain they do this by allowing things to
pass through permeability of course
means that it's easier for things to
pass through so basically the cell walls
are made of fats when you take omega 3
that fat is omega 3 and that makes it
easier for these pass through which
speeds up the communication in the brain
and omega threes got loads of other
benefits too besides that it's supposed
to be good for testosterone as well
those of other things we don't generally
get enough omega-3 in our diets it's
quite hard to get in our diet especially
because of the mercury content and
things like tuna which I eat in copious
amounts anyways
but also because there's so much Ritalin
there's so much omega-6 and everything
we eat omega-6 is used in as a
preservative in a lot of foods and it
competes with omega-3 omega-6 isn't bad
for you but the more omega-6 you have
the less omega-3 you probably have and
you have too much omega-6 and not enough
omega-3 so don't take an omega-6
supplement take an omega-3 and try any
oily fish and try and avoid processed
meals and if you have too much omega-6
and not enough omega-3 this may also
lead to inflammation which can cause
brain fog as well as damaging your mood
possibly even leading to depression so
that's another benefit of taking omega-3
it's also newer protective against
Alzheimer's and age-related cognitive
decline as is caffeine by the way so the
stock I'm taking at the moment is
hopefully covering many different
aspects of cognitive health and
hopefully leading to long-term benefits
as well as short-term benefits new
plasticity extra energy and just the
whole gamut creatine is another one like
those eleme which is more often thought
of as an athletic booster or and
bodybuilding supplement the role of
creatine is to recycle ATP ATP is the
most basic form of energy when you can
seem glucose sugar the body turns it
into ATP to use it stands for adenosine
triphosphate this allows you to have a
small burst of energy you store it in
the muscles ready so that you can move
creatine allows you to recycle the ATP
and let's get just a little bit more
energy out of the ATP that's stored in
your muscles so you can reuse it when
you consume this then you can get a
couple of extra seconds of energy from
your ATP that's why it's useful for body
builders and also it improves water
attention to the muscles but for the
brain it's good because it's providing
your neurons with more energy and
studies show that it boosts scores in IQ
tests so yeah not a lot of people know
that but creatine is also a very good
nootropic with no health downsides and
all good stuff so more people should
take it even non bodybuilders so there's
all the nutritional nootropics
nutritional nootropics that I like that
replace things you could get in your
diet
one more I'm interested in though that's
a bit different is still tip still tip
is designed to improve long-term
potentiation which is the strength
between different neural connections so
brain plasticity is the word that
describes your brain's ability to change
shape and grow new connections and this
makes those connections stronger so in
theory enhances learning that's the idea
anyways the stack makes a lot of sense
in that all the ingredients are chosen
from based on studies but there is some
disagreement as to whether or not they
all are in enough quantities to work in
humans and to actually improve brain
plasticity there's mixed comments and
reviews and you can look at it in more
detail on my website there's nothing in
here that will harm you and I like the
idea and theory of boosting brain
plasticity a lot and that's why I also
supplement the zetas may and want to
replace that with the 3 & 8 but whether
or not this does that I'm not sure I
took the whole pot and I must say I
maybe felt something because when you
increase BDNF brain-derived neurotrophic
factor the nootropic there the
neurotransmitter that is most
responsible for plasticity you do find
that it correlates with a kind of
increased desire to learn and increase
focus and it does correlate with
dopamine which is the neurotransmitter
that does those things so yeah maybe it
works maybe it doesn't I'd like to look
at this in more detail and I am finding
ways to more accurately measure the
effects of nootropic so that's something
we'll be looking at in future I'm also
going to be making a video in future all
about newtripper to the boost brain
plasticity so it'll be like a plasticity
stack or I call it the plasticity
protocol because I read too many comics
but yes stay tuned for that if you think
that sounds at all interesting and
something else you might have noticed
then about my new triptych stack here is
that a lot of the things do double up
ACD do double up as bodybuilding
supplements and of course that's partly
because I'm into the gym and I like
working out beautiful
but it's also because actually a there's
little crossover between things that
boost your brainpower and things of PC
muscle power and B I think it's great to
have a stack that's combined that
combines both because well that way it's
just a performance stack isn't it's not
just a brain step or a body's second
having a performance stack is cool so
yeah a bit rambling I know I tend to do
that but I hope you found some use there
out of what I'm recommending here so
I've got the SIL tip and the limitless
brain both of which I think are
interesting limitless brain for boosting
short-term performance still tech for
boosting brain plasticity very
interested in that but needs to do more
research vitamin and mineral supplements
zetas major sleep not essential I'm
going to plate it with magnesium free
and eight like I say because I'm already
getting the zinc in the b6 elsewhere but
it could be an interesting one Peter
tribe you haven't read it before
creatine for increased energy and muscle
benefits and omega-3 fish oil for
improving communication between the
brain cells those are the nootropics I
like right now and I find that this
stack does boost my brainpower I've been
feeling particularly productive awake
well slept etc as a result of these so
give it a go if you like and also let me
know what nutrifix
you're using in the comments or if there
are any others you would like me to
cover yeah thanks very much for watching
stay tuned for more videos like this
won't be so long until the next one now
also I do videos on fitness bodybuilding
productivity working online
transhumanism technology etc so yeah
check out my channel and you can find
some of those videos let me know what
you think have a look at my Twitter and
my Facebook and my Instagram you can
find the links down below talk to me in
the comments I'd love to hear from you
and if you enjoyed this video please
consider like sharing and subscribing
because it helps me a great deal thanks
very much for watching once more and I
will catch you next time bye for now